algunos residentes de isión que todavía
no tienen acceso a internet no saben que
este sitio existe estaba escondido
detrás de las posiciones del ejército
ruso en los bosques A las afueras de la
ciudad pero el viernes bajo los focos de
los medios de comunicación
internacionales los trabajadores
municipales y los investigadores
iniciaron el sombrío trabajo de
exhumación de las tumbas hasta ahora
hemos exhumado unos 25 cadáveres verá
como hemos terminado esta fosa ahora
envolveremos el cuerpo y luego pasaremos
a la siguiente y así procederemos con
nuestras investigaciones hasta que
hayamos recorrido todo el territorio
algunos fueron enterrados con sus
documentos
estos eran Soldados del ejército
ucraniano la causa de la muerte se
determinará solo después de la autopsia
las explosiones son obra de las unidades
de desminado cercanas los soldados
parecen haber sido enterrados en fosas
comunes los civiles individualmente los
enterradores locales dijeron que muchos
murieron por las Bombas o los cohetes
durante el asalto ruso hay seúl en marzo
y fueron enterrados de nuevo aquí más
tarde pero no todos
motusco se encontró una cuerda alrededor
del cuello de este hombre y signos de
que esta cuerda fue utilizada para
asfixiarlo lo que significa que puede
haber sido estrangulado
aunque no se puede ver en las imágenes
es la terrible sensación de muerte que
permea este bosque no se sabe
exactamente cuánta gente hay aquí ni
Cómo murieron lo que sí está claro es
que estaban vivos antes de que la
invasión rusa comenzara el 24 de febrero